each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today we have Roman Lucien here from he
actually works at Microsoft Research at
Station Q in Santa Barbara and he's
visiting today he graduated from
University of Minnesota and then spent
three years at University of Maryland
before coming to station Q where he has
been for a year just about a year so he
is going to talk to us about topological
quantum computing with my Arana fermions
thank you very much for introduction and
for the invitation to come here and give
a talk it's always a pleasure to visit
redmond so this is Microsoft Station Q
here you know this is a view from our
building we are located in very nice
campus UCSB campus and our group
consists of mathematicians physicists
and computer scientists and what we are
trying to do and we are trying to
explore these the this interface between
the two between three different
disciplines to build a quantum computer
and the particular approach that we
pursue is topological quantum computing
and I'll explain today what what this
this is about and why this approach is
very promising so most of the people in
our group our theory sure but they also
coordinate is many experimentalist
around the world and we just asked them
to do some experiments to test our ideas
so so this is the outline for my talk
I'll start with some introduction of
quantum computing and I'll explain why
it is advantage advantageous and then
I'll explain what a topological quantum
computing and present some realistic
systems where we think we can implement
this
this approach so so as you know from
everyday world that most of the physics
most of our everyday life can be
explained in terms of classical laws
Newton's law Maxwell equations of
electromagnetism etc but if you scratch
the surface we can quickly quickly
realize that the world is actually
quantum mechanical and these are devices
that we use in you know everyday life
and some of the things in those devices
is actually based on on quantum physics
and transistors tunneling tunneling is a
particular quantum phenomena in lasers
the fact that you have a discrete
two-level system so you have
quantization of levels there's also a
quantum mechanical phenomena in MRI the
fact that atoms have nuclear spins
nuclear spin is also a quantum
mechanical object so so I would say we
use these properties in everyday life
but we use them not in not to the
fullest extent and in order to do that
we have to go back to the principle in
order to explore quantum mechanics in
depth we have to go back and use the the
most fundamental principle of quantum
mechanics the principle of superposition
so if quantum mechanics postulates that
if you have a state sy then this state
can be a superposition of two other
states 0 and 1 and principle of
superposition can be illustrated in this
very very nice experiment double slit
experiment which we all know and love so
if the so if the light was was I mean
the light is the wave so so principle
superposition is just it's just the fact
that we add the amplitudes for the light
and because we add amplitudes not
probabilities we can have this
interference pattern on the screen so
the idea is you you send the light he
here and then the light can go either
through this pass or this pass and then
depending on the position of the screen
you'll see a sequence of these dark and
bright spots and so that's this
principle of superposition because you
have to add the amplitudes for
electromagnetic field and then squares
the amplitudes to get the intensity on
the screen so long time ago in 1982
Richard Feynman very famous American
physicist asked the following question
can we explore the god-given resource
the resource of quantum mechanics for
for something useful for quantum
computation for example so if you do
that then you immediately realize that
because each of this each state of the
system if it's a two-level system can be
in superposition then if you have and
such two-level systems then the
information that is encoded in these two
in such a system scales as two to the M
so it's scales exponentially was the
size was the size of the system and
that's actually something we are trying
to explore in quantum computing we're
trying to explore the fact that we can
store much more information in quantum
reality and in classical rial where you
can just have zero and wants so what is
the potential application of quantum
information processing actually there
are there are many and for example if
you want to solve a system and you want
to it would like to understand say
property is a particular system like a
chemical reaction that involves some
quantum mechanics then we can simulate
that on on this corner computer so we
can basically solve any quantum system
by just programming it into our quantum
computer and and running the simulation
another application is factorization of
large integer numbers and that basically
triggered this this interest in quantum
computing because the
this particular operation leads to this
particular algorithm leads to
exponential speed-up so our security
will be in danger if we have a quantum
computer or maybe we can invent
something more complicated quantum
encryption another thing which is fairly
useful is quantum search algorithm and
it's basically a search of an entering a
database but here we have algebraic
speed up rather than exponential it's
also very useful and finally quantum
cryptography so quantum physics allows
you to send information securely and the
security is guaranteed by by the physics
and and so so these are just a few of
potential applications people are
working and discovering more and more
algorithms but what I would like to talk
today is actually how to implement how
to build a quantum computer
what are the systems that are suitable
to do this task and khrysta here he is
doing research and quantum algorithms so
you if you are interested you might want
to talk to her and learn some more
details about this so in classical
computer we have a bit which is a basic
logical element it has 0 and 1 so we
need to find something similar in
quantum computer and it's called cubed
or quantum bit essentially cubed is a
quantum two-level system so these are
the two levels and and by controlling
the coupling so so very often two-level
system is represented by spin so you can
have essentially Pauli algebra and and
if you control all the couplings if you
control all the couplings with a spin
then essentially you can program the
state you want to you want to get so a
qubit is a controllable two-level system
you can drag this vector by applying
some gate by applying some gate voltages
and signals and changing these
coefficients you can drag this vector
and put anywhere on a blocks here you
want so basically you can change all the
coefficients
in here so that's an idea so you would
like to have a controllable two-level
system well these are the potential
realizations of these controllable
quantum two-level systems and I would
say they come in two flavors so the
first one is based on microscopic
degrees of freedom so like a nuclear
spin in MRI this is a microscopic degree
of freedom or position of an atom in
particular location that's also
microscopic degrees degree of freedom
and another another type of qubits are
another type of Q it is based on
collective degrees of freedom and these
are superconducting qubits and actually
also topological qubits that I will talk
about today so the idea is there is that
a lot of electrons they behave in in a
coherent way so that it's like an
orchestra you work we would you listen
to Orchestra and you see that everybody
is following the same you know pattern
so the same thing happens here to the to
the extent that you can describe ten to
the nine electrons by a single variable
so so that's debate that that's that's
what happens in in superconductors and
in topological qubits we would like to
you know we would like to have that but
even go beyond that that paradigm so
what are the problems in quantum
computing I mean these these approaches
are fairly developed now and people have
created these two-level systems they
manipulate them they couple them and try
to play with them but there is a
fundamental problem and the fundamental
problem is called decoherence so if you
have a microscopic system and you want
to couple to this microscopic system and
control its position on it blocks here
it turns out that there are other
couplings which are unavoidable and we
cannot just filter out useful couplings
and say from from
from unuseful couplings so these
unavoidable say harmful couplings lead
to two errors in our quantum computation
and this process is called decoherence
so so that's that that's that's why we
talked to experimentalist because
quantum phenomena occurring in the lab
and in the lab you really have to make
your hands dirty and you know so the
process of quantum decoherence something
that people known from the lab
experiments and and they measure it so
they start in some state and then they
see that this state will will decay to a
ground state for example if you start in
the excited state with with time so your
information can be preserved for some
for some time and you would like to
actually we would like to try to correct
these errors but it turns out that
unlike in classical computers where
error correction is is very developed
and fairly successful in quantum
computers it is very hard to do and the
reason it is very hard to do it because
if you want to correct more and more you
need to introduce more and more
resources so there is that there are
some approaches where people established
what should be the error rate and this
error rate is 10 to the minus 5 so it's
fairly fairly small and so far we we are
trying to achieve this error rate but
it's very hard so yeah so you have a
decay time and you have a speed of
particular operation so if you divide
these two that will be your error rate
excuse me
depends on particular system so I think
we are reaching ten to the minus four I
insert in certain qubits but the thing
is something there is something
unexplored here this is error rate for
some models and if these scales the
system this this actually decay rate
might also scale with the size of a
system so this area it needs needs to be
explored more especially when you have
more and more qubits together because
there is also a collective effect but
what we are trying to do at station
queuing Santa Barbara you're trying to
solve this problem in a different way
we're trying to find a system which will
be immune to these errors at the
hardware level so rather than having to
correct for these errors we would like
to build the hardware which is fault
tolerant and the idea for this approach
actually goes back to somebody who spent
a lot of time here in Redmond Aleksey
kita who is now professor at Caltech and
he said the following thing he said well
let's try to encode our information in
reading and local degrees of freedom and
the errors that we usually have they
come from some local fluctuations local
changes in the environment but if you
have if information is stored and
locally then it will be insensitive to
these local perturbation so you can
think about this in using a topologist
view and topologist they say well these
three objects are actually identical
they all have this just a single hole so
as long as we don't do anything drastic
to the system as long as we don't
destroy this hole the the information
which is encoded in in this geometry
will be protected you can bite a piece
of this doughnut and the information is
still going to be preserved and so
that's the idea you would like to find a
system which which will be insensitive
to these local perturbations because we
encode the information in a completely
different way
so when so usually we are talking about
topological phases of matters is the
phases of matter where experimentally
observable quantities can be insensitive
to local perturbations and one of these
one of the well-known examples in
condensed matter physics is quantum Hall
state quantum Hall state is the state of
a semi conductor in a strong magnetic
field so so these two discoveries
actually were awarded Nobel Prizes in 95
and 98 and there is some difference
between them but I don't want to go into
details as far as this is concerned this
is the topological phase of matter so if
you take an integer quantum Hall state
which is the state say in lower magnetic
field and you apply electric fuel to the
system then there will be current
flowing in the perpendicular direction
and then if you just measure this
current and find a whole conductivity of
the system this is essentially the
coefficient proportional to the electric
field applied but you'll find that this
coefficient will be proportional to
fundamental constants a squared over H
times the integer and this integer is
accurate to 10 to the minus 9 so you
take example of different geometry the
sample can have different disorder
realization different parameters but
still this quantity is protected to ten
to the minus nine nine in fact this
whole conductivity is a standard of
resistance now know you measure
something and something is close to one
but how close it to one right so I
change parameters in the system and it
still stays in one whereas in some other
system non topological you change
something this this this this
coefficient will change completely it's
going to be zero
it's gonna be ten so what the point is
that this integer this number is as
close to one with the curacy ten to the
minus nine and it doesn't matter what I
do to the system I know it was a billion
it wouldn't be a billion at 1 I see it
is always larger yeah I think yeah it's
an integer but it's yeah it's accurate
so there are the software approaches to
error correction
hard work toward ended that uses
replications right and senses what
happened that the state is not captured
by a single particle instead if it is
captured by a lot of repetition so what
is the fundamental difference why not do
it in a software just so many
repetitions well I mean you can you if
you refer to collective nature of the
degrees of freedom in which we are
encoding information as as repetition
then in this sense yeah there is a there
is some similarity but but but but you
have to realize that you know there is
just a single parameter that
characterizes a system which consists of
a look you know ten to the ten electrons
and we don't have to control each of the
electrons it just happens that the
nature does it in in a particular way
now if I have a large system then the
number of electrons can be 10 to the 23
or you know even larger and I don't have
to control each of them but I can
characterize the state just by the
singles by a single parameter so it's
different from error correction where
you control different elements
separately right so so there are
similarities and there are differences
the answer question
so so that's an example of a topological
phase of matter and that's the phase of
matter which is the state of which is
not very sensitive to local
perturbations and what you want to try
to find is a state which is similar but
has additional properties it's even more
sophisticated state of matter and this
this
it's called non abelian topple on this
phase is called non abelian topological
phase so once you find such phase and
I'll give some examples where we predict
these phases can occur we also have to
be able to manipulate certain
excitations in these systems they are
called quasi particles or engines so
these are the candidate systems and in
today's talk I will I will spend some
time on superconductors and I'll show
you that superconductors are very
interesting systems which can actually
be engineered so in some sense we are
trying to engineer this state by
combining various properties of
different materials so I mentioned the
words not the word non-abelian and this
word on a billion is at the heart of the
topological quantum computing proposal
so that's so let me explain why this is
so when when when as a freshman you know
in the graduate school I took quantum
mechanics I was taught that there are
bosons and fermions there are two
particles bosons and fermions but that's
true only in three-dimensional world and
the reason it's true in three dimensions
comes from this argument so we know that
if you take a wave function of the
system and try to exchange two particles
then depending whether they have bosonic
of fermionic statistics the wave
function will pick up a plus or minus
sign and the reason there are just these
two possibilities comes to the you know
essentially a two reality of abrade
group in three dimensions so if i
exchange these two particles and then i
will exchange
two particles twice so essentially I
return to the same point so I did some
operation on the system but I can deform
this loop I can essentially take
advantage of this degree of freedom
outside of the board and essentially de
forma to to a zero to a point which
means I have to return to essentially
the same the same thing and which means
that this operation of exchanging T t
square should be equal to one and if T
squared is equal to one the only
possibility is that T is equal to plus
minus one and that's why you have only
bosons and fermions but if you take two
dimensions in two dimensions we have
more possibilities because we don't have
this degree of freedom we don't have if
you imagine if you constrain our
particles to the plane we don't have
this degree of freedom and so these
these exchanges are actually non-trivial
so they you cannot deform it to this
argument doesn't hold and that was the
prediction made by two norwegian
scientists and Lena Zimmer came and also
Frank will check from MIT in 1980s and
it has been realized later that such
particles exist in these two dimensional
system quantum Hall systems and there
are there are there are situations there
where when you exchange you pick up the
phase which can be anything that's why
these particles in two dimensions are
called onion which means any phase
should be non abelian statistics non
abelian statistics is happens when you
have the generous e in the in the many
buddy ground state so let's imagine we
have many states which which have the
same energy and then such exchanges that
I'm talking about here can induce
certain transformations between these
many body ground states so then I cannot
justify this operation as as just this
phase it can be described by a matrix
and that's what something that we are
trying to exploit here we're trying to
exploit the fact that when you have a
non-abelian statistics then exchange in
different particles between each other
can be explained in terms of different
matrices and math uses do not commute so
we can make the various combinations and
encode information in in in these states
that's one stretch of extreme yeah so we
have a yeah you have a state which has
many particles you know X n so X 1 X 2
and I'm writing a function which
explains the state and then I can take
two particles from this state and try to
exchange them together so I can exchange
X 1 and X 3 and that will be described
by a matrix M or I can exchange X 2 and
X 3 and that's going to be explained by
matrix n because because in three
dimensions as I explained the the
exchange is variables the braids group
is trivial so two exchanges give you
just one and so the the square root of
one can be either plus or minus one
additional degree of freedom weary and
full
but if you puncture the plane you cannot
yes what do you puncture in well you
have a particle physical particle
sitting somewhere and if you can go
around this particle then we can avoid
the singularity but if you don't have a
degree of freedom it's like having a
plane with this defect which has a line
and you cannot just go around line so
that's that's the difference that's the
way to think about it and the reason we
are trying to avoid we can avoid the
coherence here because these
manipulations never involve excited
state of the system so in the previous
proposal where we had quantum bits but
say conventional quantum bits they
always involved excited and ground
states so in some superposition between
0 & 1 and we know that well excited
states they decay so they relaxed the
ground state for lifetime is limited
information soon
- energy doesn't have to be excited
state well that's not an eigenstate of
the system this superposition is not an
eigenstate of the system
to position doesn't have to be that's
understandable
well 0 & 1 refers to ground state and
excited state right and you're trying
and you're saying it's a superposition
well
I'm just confused as to why what I'll
say about the second right so okay maybe
I'll just draw something here so this is
a two level system it's two level system
has a ground state
I mean I can write 0 1 side-by-side then
it's a degenerate two level system right
so so so if you have a degenerate two
level system that it's kind of similar
what I'm saying but this degeneracy is
many buddy degeneracy so the reason it
doesn't work if you have a degenerate
two level system which is kind of local
because you add some small perturbation
and that's this degeneracy is going to
be splitted so so this degeneracy is
accidental and you change something your
apparatus and degeneres is gone
reasonable very small very very few
exactly so so this is not the robust
degeneracy but you actually get into the
point that I will explain in the next
slide so you would like to create at the
general system which is robust which is
robust to these small perturbations are
you trying to use these degeneracies the
robot degeneracies to encode the
information okay
so so that's the basic idea that's why
if you have a state which is known a
billion state then you do manipulations
in the ground state doesn't invoke any
excited state in the information it's
going to be robust and this robustness
will be guaranteed by the quantum
mechanics by physics so it turns out
that the particles that that that the
state that satisfies these properties is
the state which carries my Arana
fermions so that's why my topic today
was quantum computing with my runner
fermions if you find my runner fermions
then you'll find a state which will
satisfy these properties so what is my
run a fermion anyway we know about
fermions now what is my run a fermion
what's so special about this Madonna for
me it's an interesting object which was
predicted a long time ago in 1937 by a
Torah marinum who asked the question in
the context of high-energy physics
whether all was a Dirac equation which
describes essentially
spin spin 1/2 which corresponds to spin
1/2 particles has to be necessarily
complex and then she showed that by
choosing a particular representation you
can make equation real and therefore
this should be that there should be a
real solution of this equation and if
there is a real solution of equation
then essentially the particle will be
the same as its own antiparticle and
since then there has been a lot of
search in particle physics high-energy
physics supersymmetry which is also
related to high-energy physics and also
solid state systems but as of now we
don't have a convincing convincing
evidence for for the existence and them
I would like to present one role to
overcome this problem and I'll present
complete proposal where you can find
these minor others
first question what question is why they
confirm you
well they obey anti commutation
relations which are fermionic
and now if you if you if you if you
really split the rag equation to two I
mean you can always split complex number
into real parts but the point is that in
this Marana presentation there is no
complex part it is just real part so if
you count degrees of freedom it's a real
equation the real equation has a real
solution so if you have a real solution
then it means that the complex part is
gone but I look I also get to this in
the next slide actually in this slide no
no you can always they can have complex
solutions but you if you have a real
equation you can for always find a basis
where there is a real solution if you
have a complex equation there is no
basis where you find a real solution
so so really this my run a fermion is a
real you can think about it as a real
part of Dirac fermion and if I want if I
want to construct the Dirac fermion I
have to take these to my levels
so our intuition actually comes from
having Dirac fermions metals we describe
everything by Dirac fermions and this
Dirac fermion that I create from to my
runners it's very special because but
it's it's it's now a composite object
and these two my runners layer is
depicted in this picture can be far away
from each other
so essentially this we created if you
have Maya Ranas you'll have a fermion
which will be you know very non-local
and this nonlocality helps us to make a
protected systems against decoherence
yes the state is is represented here by
the fact was this whether it's occupied
or unoccupied by particular Dirac
formula so so I have I created
artificially this Dirac fermion okay and
now I want to enumerate my Hilbert space
by States and I can enumerate by either
saying well this this this this mode is
unoccupied then it's 0 or it's occupied
which is this which which is which is
denoted by this then it's kind of 1 and
so my logical qubit is the qubit which
is either occupied or unoccupied by this
Dirac fermion and and because of that if
I have many of these particles then from
to and my runners I can roughly create n
qubits and so that's the idea you have
these my runners on the plane and you
know how you have a Hilbert space that
they correspond to and this Hilbert
Hilbert space will be degenerate because
these my runners they are sitting at
zero energy so there is a degeneracy
involved
well it's a complex right object so each
of them each of these two are real but
now if I conjugate this I'll pick up a
minus sign so the definition of Dirac
fermion is that C and C conjugated are
not equal to each other and I ran a
fermion they equal to each other so it's
essentially a half of degree of freedom
so my arañas one my run is a half of
Dirac fermion it's only real part of
Dirac fermion so so now I wanted to
illustrate why exchanging these
particles will actually lead to
something non-trivial and what why this
happens in the system so suppose now I
make a little I make the situation a
little bit more complicated I add
another direct formula which is
localized between a three and a four and
then I can say well my Hilbert State my
Hilbert space can be encoded in as this
mode occupied or an occupied or this
mode occupied and unoccupied and there
are four states which which essentially
enumerate this this Hilbert space and
now I can do something very non-trivial
because I can take a half of my fermion
which is encoded here an exchange with
another half of the formula which is
encoded here so normally in other system
you would take one electron and exchange
with another electron but here because
this electron is very non-local it's
actually a composite object you can take
a half of election in exchange with
another half of electron and that's why
some you know we are doing something
non-trivial and if you just check the
math you can you will find that you know
the state you will end up will be
different and that's basically a simple
quantum operate contemn gate operation
red and blue
oh there is no significant it's just the
you know just labeling which which ones
we are breeding
so this is the this is the excitement in
the community because of these ideas and
the reason there is such so much
excitement because we found how to
borrow a trick from superconductor and
use this this this trick to find the
systems where my Rana fermions can be
can be detected
and the idea is as following so so I'm
gonna give us some sort of some sort of
introduction for superconductors but if
you guys are familiar with
superconductors I can just skip it
so I'll should they okay so so
superconductors are actually very
interesting state it's very super
connectivities very interesting state of
matter it's a state of matter where at
low temperatures once you lower the
temperature the state doesn't have any
resistance so if I measure if I take a
mercury and I lower the temperature and
measures the resistance of mercury as a
function of temperature then at some
point the resistance is essentially
vanishing and that was discovered by
kamerlingh onnes in nineteen nineteen
eleven and soon as the discovery two
years after discovery he was awarded
Nobel Prize and the theory of
superconductivity was and remained
unsolved until 1957 where these three
theorists bardeen cooper and schrieffer
came up with the explanation why this
happens why you have zero resistance
state at low temperature and the basic
idea is that electrons in a metal they
kind of glue to each other and they form
Cooper pairs they from two electrons you
can create a boson quote which which
which is called Cooper pair and bosons
and fermions have different very
different properties at low temperatures
bosons want to occupy a zero momentum
state they want to condense and sit in
the same level whereas fermions they
don't want to do that and so and that
actually is an explanation for for the
zero resistance bosons can have zero
resistance because there is coherence
between them but there is another
property which is important in the
theory of BCS the theory of BCS has the
state that the Hamiltonian they affect
your Hamiltonian that is described by
the in
yes theory mix the states with different
different particle number so the
particle number is not conserved and
that's actually key to having my arañas
because if the particle number is not
conserved in Hamiltonian and I wanted to
say that the theory of super
conductivity is so developed that we can
even explain this cool stuff when you
have a magnet on top of superconductors
this magnet can be levitated because of
the Meister effect so we know super
chemically super conductivity pretty
well now
please conventional S wave super
conductivity but I was going to say that
this fact that superconducting
Hamiltonian doesn't conserve the the
particle number is is actually key to to
the following observation so in order to
diagonalize Hamiltonian which doesn't
concern particle number I have to have a
superposition between sort of particles
and holes or particle electron creation
and annihilation operators and the
superposition has some amplitudes U and
V and if I want to create a my Arana
fermion all i need to do in a
superconductor is to find the state
where these two amplitudes
are actually the same well up to
communication then you can just check
because sy goes to side daggers that you
know if u is equal to the star that will
get a particle which will be self
conjugate so that that is in my lana
from you so where do we find these
states at zero energy well where do we
find these states with such such
properties well we find them whenever we
have an equal superposition of a
particle in the hole and where do we
find such superposition essentially
somewhere between some somewhere between
the empty and occupied band so somewhere
here so we have to look at zero energies
and if you find the state at zero energy
such state actually by construction will
have these properties and the reason
that it has by construction these
properties actually as something
fundamental in in in in the theory of
super conductivity
the there is certain symmetry in the
theory of super conductivity which is
called particle-hole symmetry and the
symmetry tells you that if you have a
solution which corresponds to energy E
then there should be another solution
which corresponds to energy of minus E
now if I have a solution with zero
energy you can just check that this
symmetry guarantees that you should be
equal to the star and therefore the
state that is sitting at zero energy
will be self conjugate yes yes that's
right this is a model for now
but I'll give you a physical realization
later I'll show you how one can enslaves
the spin so so so so basically we are
guaranteed to have this zero energy
state if as you correctly pointed out we
have spinless fermions
now this zero energy state is not going
to be accidental like in the other
example it's going to be protected by
this symmetry you see the symmetry tells
us that we should have states that come
in pairs e and minus e now if I try to
if I add some perturbation to the
Hamiltonian and I try to lift the state
from zero then it's not going to have a
partner and since it's not going to have
a partner that should violate
particle-hole symmetry so this these
changes are not allowed so unless we do
something drastic to the system and we
completely destroy it leak perturbations
do not lift this degeneracy
so it's it is robust okay now I'll give
you some examples of spinless for now
but then I will show how one can
engineers the spinless Hamiltonians from
spin fool fermions so why do we have
these zero energy states and where do we
have these zero energy states so there
is a simple model which one can write
and it's a super conductivity model
where the order parameter is
proportional to momentum so this
coefficient depends on the
it's proportional to P and within simple
this simple model what I wanted to
illustrate here is that without any
fine-tuning you will have these zero
energy states so let's imagine that we
have a situation where this chemical
potential is sort of varying in space
like this then whenever chemical
potential is positive we have a methyl
but now it becomes negative we have an
insulator because there is no there is
no Fermi surface so there is no the
fermions cannot populate but it's not
dense the density of state is zero so so
if you assume this configuration
actually this configuration models the
one dimensional system was and at these
points now I'll do another
simplification and I'll say that well
this chemical potential changes very
slowly in space okay then I can drop
essentially higher order derivatives and
what they end up with is something well
known in high energy physics it's called
one plus one Dirac equation which we are
solving for zero energy
one plus one Dirac equation is very well
studied and in particular it is
well-known that whenever the mass of
this Dirac equation which here plays the
role of chemical potential changes a
sign you'll have these these states you
have them bound States in other words
you don't need to know high energy
physics you can just say I have this
equation I want to find the normalizable
solution of this differential equation
and what you find that there are
normalizable solutions at the ends so so
bottom line if I have this spin last
people superconductor at the ends of one
dimensional system I'll have zero energy
solution and these zero energy states
will be robust against small
perturbations so I don't need to
fine-tune any parameters like Delta or
mu or and anything as long as I have a
p-wave spin let's view a superconductor
I'll have these states so so that's idea
we need to somehow engineer as
inglis superconductor how can we do that
when the all electrons have spin so
there are two ingredients that we will
use and first ingredient is spin orbit
interaction so spin orbit interaction is
an interaction which couples spin to a
mentum and if you can somehow and slave
spin to the momentum we can get rid of
this half of the degree of freedom that
is redundant and we can make the system
effectively spin less and the second
thing is superconducting proximity
effect so we want to induce rather than
looking for these materials in nature
you want to have the superconducting
state on demand so then we will use some
other superconductor and make and create
some interfaces and that those
interfaces will have a necessary States
so so I'll be talking today about
superconductors semiconductor
heterostructures and these hetero
structures will have essentially the
required properties so first let me just
spend a few minutes on spin orbit
coupling actually spin orbit coupling in
condensed matter systems appears quite
generically it appears because at the
interface between different materials
you might have an electric field it's a
very strong electric field in fact and
then if the motion of electrons is say
constrained to this plane then if I make
you know essentially the Lorentz
transformation and go to a rest frame of
this electron this electric field will
induced a magnetic field in this rest
frame which will be pointing up and if
the electron has a spin
obviously it interacts with magnetic
fields so therefore I have a coupling
between the spin and an electric field
and this is the this effect is called
mean this mechanism is called Raja
mechanism and this this mechanism is can
be written in the in turn
in in this forum so I will use this in
the rest of my talk and what is
important for this raj bus spin-orbit
coupling that it actually does the job
because now you can see that spin the
spins are enslaved to the momentum which
live on different Fermi surfaces so the
spins they precess around the Fermi
surfaces the eyes in clockwise or
counterclockwise fashion the second
ingredient that I will need is the
proximity effect so what is proximity
effect well you have a semiconductor and
you put it very close to superconductor
so electrons in the semiconductor will
tunnel into superconductor and for some
short time they will feel these
correlations superconducting
correlations so they will inherit these
properties from the superconductor and
effectively it's a way to create a
Hamiltonian which doesn't conserve
particle number because because what I
can do I can send in an electron and
then measure the the and and this
electron will be reflected as a whole
and as a result of this the Cooper pair
the two electron will be emitted in this
in this superconductor so if I want to
describe this kind of special scattering
that appears at this interface I have to
add a term in the Hamiltonian which
describes disappearance of two electrons
from the semiconductor so that's
effectively a term which allows to break
particle number conservation okay so
that's the proposal
so suppose we first take this
one-dimensional system which has the
Rajpath spin orbit coupling and we also
have some magnetic field along the
longitudinal direction and so what
happens in in in the geometry that first
the this rajma coupling separates the
spectrum into two parabolas but then
this additional term essentially opens
up a gap in the spectrum at zero
so at the end of the day if the chemical
potential is somewhere here you will
have a single Fermi surface so it's
gonna be if you have a single Fermi
surface which is kind of tricky because
this because I started from a spin full
system but in in the basis that
diagonalizes this Hamiltonian I will
have spin less particles I have single
species of particles that live on this
single Fermi surface and so that's how
we get get around the Fermi on doubling
you do the spin degeneracy the the
nanowires actually that are useful for
our purposes are indium arsenide and
indium antimony nanowires and for
technical reasons they are very
favorable they have very large couplings
very large couplings to to magnetic
field to Raj but also Razvi spin orbit
coupling and they have very good
contacts with metals so now this is a
technical slide but what I wanted to
present the schematics why this state
this complicated Hamiltonian is related
to this spin last P wave superconductor
so you have so now let's imagine that we
have a wire that is lying on top of the
superconductor and then you'll have
these additional terms you use a
proximity effect then let's do the
following trick let's first diagonalize
this part and then rewrite the other
part in the basis that is diagonal where
the single particle part is diagonal so
what happens when the chemical potential
is here that essentially this band is is
unoccupied and I can project the system
I can just keep the lowest band and if I
do that all these terms that are here I
will throw away sigh plus component and
so they are gone and now what I'm left
with is essentially single component for
single species now index minus is kind
of a spin index and I have a p-wave
superconductor okay so this construction
allows us to map this spin fool model to
a spin last PFF superconductor and I
showed you that spin less beware
superconductors have zero modes at the
ends so therefore this model should have
zero modes at the ends as well and and
you can see that these zero the that
these these zero modes can be only if if
the chemical potential is somewhere in
the gap if if the chemical potential is
somewhere here then this construction
that I showed you doesn't work so what
we find we find that this system can
generate my run of fermions on-demand ok
so I change some parameter in the system
and I can go from a state which has
these modes to a state which doesn't
have these modes okay and you can keep
all the details keep the full
Hamiltonian and check these ideas
numerically so so that's what you find
so this is the plot of the density of
states as a function of the length of
this wire so this is the length and in
the function of energy and it's just
numerical diagnose ation of the
Hamiltonian and then computing the
density of states and you can see that
you have zero energy states at the ends
where the magnetic field is in the right
regime and and in the opposite regime
you just don't have anything so they
disappear how we did oh it's Mathematica
Mathematica plot you can do many things
with Mathematica these days all right so
that's basically the system that we'd
like to use to build our topological
quantum computer well one can also say
well what if your theory is missing some
important ingredients and how do you
test your theory well there are simple
experiments that one can do to test this
this theory I mean the fact that you
have zero energy states in in one phase
and you
don't have it in the other face should
be seen in the experiments and the
simplest experiment is to try some kind
of a tunneling or scandal in scan
scanning tunneling microscopy and try to
tunnel in the end of this wire if you
have a state at zero energy then the
tunneling should be allowed if you don't
have it then the tunneling should be
forbidden and what you should find
actually there is a Kentucky concrete
prediction that if the state is in
topological phase then this tunneling
conductance the idd should be equal to
something very Universal to e squared
over H and in the other limit it should
be exactly zero so there are other
experiments which also have very
interesting signatures of these Marana
fermions in in the system but I just
wanted to maybe talk more about quantum
computation in this audience I would be
happy to explain more about experiments
if somebody is interested in so suppose
we have this system suppose we have this
face what can we do with it well by the
way this is how the current experimental
situation this is where the current
experimental situation is so actually we
have these nanowires and we are doing
the experiments as we speak and you know
it'll keep you posted once okay right so
so these are the gates that you can
apply to change chemical potential in
the system and this is the wire lying on
top and and and beneath you have a
superconductor regular-ass a
superconductor
so how can we use these assistants for a
quantum computation so the reason there
is a very interesting effect so I
mentioned that if I change the chemical
potential somewhere I can go through the
phase transition right if I change the
chemical if I change the chemical
potential I can go from a state which
doesn't support my Arana to a state that
supports them right so suppose I change
the chemical potential only in the half
of the system where it's means that if
essentially I moved this my another
particle somewhere here and essentially
it allows me to to exchange to move
these particles and exchange them around
because if I create now a t-junction
so I can move this particle here then
move this other particle here then move
it back and so on I can do the exchange
that I could do the braiding operation
that I mentioned before
so these wires essentially allow you to
do braiding operation of the network of
these wires allow you to exchange the
particles because it's essentially a you
know two dimensional network of
one-dimensional wires and one can also
measure the state of the system by
coupling this wire so this is the wire
and this is a set of gate by by by
coupling this system to a squid so this
is the squid and you have seed Josephson
junctions and it turns out that because
the state is either occupied by an
electron or unoccupied these Josephson
junctions the squids are sensitive to us
- - and they can distinguish different
States was different from your number so
I just measure some characteristic of
the squid like splitting energy and I
will be able to distinguish the
difference between the state occupied
and unoccupied so I can be I can do the
readout of the state
fictional surfaces or engine no you can
get them for free actually so if you
have an aluminum and expose the aluminum
in you know to the air it will create a
natural layer of oxide and so this oxide
is the is a barrier and so if you
basically take them out from the vacuum
and then stick them together and after
that and you have a junction there the
basic idea is that they use oxides so
another thing that you can do you can
actually create a device which is called
topological fountain bus so so I
mentioned that the information that is
encoded in these topological degrees of
freedom is very different that the
information that is encoded in
conventional qubits where the degrees of
freedom are microscopic so if you want
to couple say conventional quantum
architecture and topological quantum
computation we need to find a bus which
you can do that and these are the ideas
which allow you to do that again it
really helps that these are
superconducting systems and here's for
example a proposal to couple a
semiconductor double dot qubit where
essentially the state is encoded by the
presence of electron or absence on this
dot so so that's one proposal and as a
proposal is to couple this this wire
network with so called transform qubit
which is just the generalization of a
charge qubit in superconductors but what
is interesting that one can then couple
these superconductors to two two photons
and photons one can teleport they can
live over large distances so here's the
example you have a strip line resonator
which it's a basically cavity with very
good mirrors and you can control the
number of photons in this cavity by
lowering the temperature
and essentially this photon couples to
this transmen qubit which is basically
the cuit which consists of these two
superconducting kind of islands large
islands and then the transform cubed
couples to topological qubit so bottom
line we also can use advantage of these
conventional qubits to do the logical
operations which are very fast in those
qubits and then teleport information
into topological space and and store the
information there so I'll leave you with
this final slide where we envision some
kind of topological quantum computer
it's basically a computing computer
which is in the delusion for each but
it's also connected to some classical
machine and you can just dial particular
tasks that you want the quantum computer
to do and and it will do the task and
then spit out the result and communicate
it to a classical computer so with this
I will end and thank you very much for
your attention
their ways well you have to exchange the
particles which tends to be slower also
also there is a one gate that we need to
teleport from somewhere from
conventional computers we know how to
make many gates with topological but
there is one gate that is missing and we
would like to teleport this gate from
the conventional yeah yeah so it's a I
understand that quantum computing is
already unconventional but you know for
the people in the field it's kind of
conventional and then topological is
unconventional you can make a grid there
is no problem you can make actually
various networks and study the
properties of these edges and surfaces
and so on
there was another question well it's not
the right question to me yeah we hope
soon I mean they started fairly recently
they actually started maybe in the
spring of this year so it's hard to
predict but they already have some good
results I mean they've tested the idea
the the parameters that we used for
example for some estimates of these
nanowires so they find that they in this
in the same ballpark so now they have to
cup all them two superconductors and you
know characterize that part chemical
potential tune into the rider you know
no they will this is not a high-energy
experiment there you just measure
something that comes out and analyze it
the next day
what is the device you're using to try
and observe the emergence of the so
tunneling experiment for example so you
just have it some normal metal tip which
is in internal contact with the end of
the wire and you will tunnel and see
whether this electron actually has some
density of states to go into or not you
know but it's it's very easy to see in
DI DV because you're just measuring the
electric signal and this electric signal
will be is a zero or something finite in
fact not just finite but something that
is 2 y squared over H in 2 times
fundamental constants so there is a very
concrete prediction this is the zero
temperature result so if you have low
temperatures sufficiently low
temperature which is doable
this is such an application ontology
could it be say the NSA what do you have
that
well if NSA has it I don't know okay but
there are some companies that are very
interested in these devices like
Lockheed Martin for example so maybe
they they might have it I don't know yes
in high-energy physics people are
looking for Mariner fermions in double
beta decay exactly okay so here in
condensed matter what we are predicting
is actually more than just my Rana be
predicting the state which has
non-abelian statistics and has
degeneracy it just happens to be that
these particles at zero energies they
satisfy my on the condition so once you
find a my Rana in solid state then it
automatically should have these
properties but in high energy it doesn't
have to be the case
correct anyways and neutrinos do it's a
matter of fact they just don't have a
lot of properties measured but this
double by the decay I think that's the
experiment that they try to do and as
far as I know that data is inconclusive
because there is not enough statistics
and they are trying to write they're
trying to reproduce this experiment but
that costs a lot of money because the
millions of dollars here it's kind of
interesting because my room is trapped
in you into that wire you know where it
is if it is right and so the tunneling
can those were to look I guess is the
way is safe right get to decide whether
there's a minor honor there was just the
end of these pairs you know exactly what
does that mean physically when you said
that you change the chemical energy to
try and kind of change the endpoint of
the wire is that yeah potentials I don't
know why it's called chemical potential
what are you doing so see I can I can
have some on top and I can change the
chemical potential well let's go there
they actually created the Institute
joint quantum Institute so they already
have a lot of people there okay so
Edinburg some of the people know
okay